>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Hessler: Well,
good afternoon, everyone.
Hope everyone didn't
have too big a lunch.
This afternoon we've got a
really great program for you,
mostly focused on the Carta
Marina and nautical charts.
Obviously, the Carta
Marina is, itself,
a large printed nautical chart,
very different from the 1507 map
and to a certain extent is
somewhat the understudied sister
of the 1507 map, which has
its own little nickname,
The Birth Certificate of America,
and various other sundry
theories associated with it.
The Carta Marina seems to have
been largely ignored except
for a few people who have actually
done very intensive work on it.
Our first speaker today, this
afternoon, Joaquim Gaspar,
is one of those scholars
who not only does intensive
and deep scholarship but
one of those scholars
who transform a discipline,
transform the study
of a particular type of object.
Joaquim, whose Dissertation
Committee I was
on when he received his Doctorate,
I'm not being one-sided here
but it was a very good
defense, basically has begun
to apply very analytical
tools to some
of the interesting
technical questions associated
with not only things like
Portolan Charts but also mysteries
like the Mercator projection, how
was it mathematically constructed.
He's done a lot of work and
published in many essays
and in Amargo Mundi
[Assumed Spelling]
and several other journals.
If you've never read
his dissertation
on Portolan Charts I would
suggest it as required reading.
He has just recently received one of
the first Millionaire Research Grant
from the European Research Council
in the history of cartography
since the European
Research Council was founded
to study the technical
developments of the Portolan Chart.
And so, without further
ado, Joaquim?
[ Applause ]
>> Joaquim Gaspar:
Thank you very much.
Before I start, let me just say
how wonderful I feel to be here
and I have to thank
John for inviting me.
Well, the title is not exactly
the same as in the program.
Anyway, I probably should say
it will be equally exciting.
Can you hear me?
Not too loud?
No, okay. I'd like to start my talk
by showing side-by-sides
two different kinds
of modern maps depicting the
same region of the world,
the well-known Chesapeake Bay.
A nautical chart on the left and
the topographical map on the right,
the differences are obvious.
In the topographical map the
formation is concentrated inland
leaving the wet areas
almost totally empty.
In the nautical chart most of
the formation is located at sea
and in the coastal areas
closest to the sea,
leaving the dry land
virtually blank.
The reasons for these
differences are, of course,
related to the different
purposes of maps and charts.
While topographical maps are
intended to depict all kinds
of general information relative
to the surface of the earth,
nautical charts are constructed
with the specific goal
of supporting marine navigation.
But, of course, these are
old news for those of you
who are acquainted
with maps and charts.
However, when we look into
the historical evolution
of nautical cartography we
realize that the differences
between these two types
of representations are much
more profound than expected.
This is the subject of
my presentation today.
I will show using examples
taken from various periods
that historically maps and nautical
charts not only have different
geneses but also were
constructed with different purposes
and according to different
principles.
The fundamental difference
between maps and charts was
in a limited way already expressed
by the late American photographer,
Hester Robinson [Assumed Spelling],
who stated in his well-known book,
Elements of Cartography and I
quote - maps are to be looked
at while charts are to be worked on.
Although Robinson's definition
is wonderfully expressive
and synthetic it doesn't
tell the whole story
or even the most exciting parts.
In my talk I will show how
closely connected are the geometry
and the construction processes of
nautical charts throughout history
to the navigational methods
they were intended to support
and how the confusion between
what should be considered
as an accurate map and accurate
charts often led to misunderstanding
and conflict between pilots,
cartographers and cosmographers.
Only in the present day
can we see more clearly
through the myths caused by
some subtle technical questions
that the protagonists of the
past were unable to interpret
and fully understand the reason
for those misunderstandings,
which is the intrinsically
different nature of maps and charts.
This is a nautical chart drawn
by a generous cartographer named
Angeli Locheti [Assumed Spelling]
in 1339 depicting the
Mediterranean, the Black Sea
and the Atlantic coast
of Europe and Africa.
It is just one example of the many
similar charts that were produced
in the workshops of Genoa, Venice
or Majorca from some uncertain date
of the early 13th Century on,
the so-called Portolan
Charts of the Mediterranean.
When we compare this representation
with the typical world maps
of the Middle Ages, usually drawn
by aerodyglatics [Assumed Spelling],
the differences in accuracy
and detail are remarkable,
so remarkable that the number of
historians probably influenced
by the old myth of the Dark Ages had
fallen into the trap of considering
that the accuracy of those
charts was not within the reach
of the medieval cartographers.
The way out of this
alley was to postulate
that the medieval Portolan
Charts were, in fact,
copies of lost prototypes made
by some ancient civilization using
sophisticated chudatic [Assumed
Spelling] methods.
However, no piece of historical
evidence has ever been produced
in support of such extraordinary
claim and the medieval origin
of Portolan Charts is
now conceptually accepted
by most historians of cartography.
Furthermore, the popular idea
that Portolan Charts
are extremely accurate
by present day standards
is not correct.
Although the general outline of
the Mediterranean with its bays,
capes and islands is
easily recognizable in them,
a closer look into
their overall geometry
and detail reveals
important inaccuracies.
The most obvious, although
by no means the only one,
is the orientation of the
Mediterranean, itself.
When we compare the
chart of Angeli Locheti
and the modern representation
of the Mediterranean,
such as this one taken
from Google Earth,
we realize that the north-south
direction in the old chart
as defined by its vertical top-down
lines is tilted counterclockwise
by an angle close to 10 degrees.
Why is that?
Could the cartographers of the
14th Century make such a mistake
when they were perfectly
aware that the direction
of the geographical map would be
easily determined by [inaudible]?
In the beginning of the
15th Century some 400 years
after the first Portolan Charts
were created Ptolemy's geography was
translated into [inaudible] and
maps of the known world based
and its extensive list
of coordinates were
produced, like this one.
Comparing the representation
of the Mediterranean
in the medieval editions
of Ptolemy's geography
with the corresponding
representations
in the contemporary
Portolan Charts one realized
that while Ptolemy's maps
are correctly oriented
to geographical maps, like this
one, Portolan Charts continued
to be tilted counterclockwise as
in the chart of Angeli Locheti.
Once again, or could the
cartographers persist
on the same mistake, this time
defined the recognized authority
of Ptolemy.
The enigma is even more
perplexing when you realize
that the overall accuracy and
detail of the Portolan Charts,
except for this particular
feature, was much better
than the one of Ptolemy's maps.
The explanation for this
apparent inconsistency is
that we are comparing two
distinct cartographical models.
While most of modern maps
and Ptolemy's representation
of the world on the left are based
on the geographical coordinates
of the places, latitudes and
longitudes, Portolan Charts
on the right were based on
navigational information collected
at sea, course between ports
measured with a magnetic compass
and distances estimated
by the pilots.
Let me underline the following
point, which is critical
for understanding the
argument of my old [inaudible],
the geometry of a map constructed
on the basis of latitudes
and longitudes is usually very
different from the one of a chart
by its magnetic courses and
distances between places.
Let me explain.
As we all know, the direction
indicated by the North Pole
of a magnetic compass,
the red one in the figure,
does not usually coincide with
the direction of the true north,
the geographical north, to the
angle between the two directions,
the angle delpha in the figure
we call magnetic declination
[Assumed Spelling].
At the time the earliest Portolan
Charts were constructed during the
13th Century the average
value of magnetic declination
in the Mediterranean was
about eight to 10 degrees,
which is also the average
tilt of those charts.
This is not by chance, of course,
because charts were oriented
with the compass top north on top.
Not only charts were
constructed using the courses
between ports measured with
the magnetic compass at sea,
but also they were used to support
navigation exactly the same way.
Putting things in simple terms, the
course actually steered by a ship,
navigating from one port
to another as indicated
by the magnetic compass should match
the corresponding ports measured
on the chart.
That would not be the case
if a common map were used.
Thus, both Ptolemy's representation
of the world and the modern map
on the left are not directly
comparable with the Portolan Chart
on the right because they belong
to distinct cartographic paradigms.
While the first two are intended
to represent the landmasses
of the world as flexible as possible
using whatever map projection is
considered the more appropriate,
Portolan Charts were
specifically conceived
to support the practice
of navigation.
Can we say that Portolan Charts were
inaccurate because the direction
between places measured on
them did not match the true
geographical directions?
It is the very concept of
accuracy which is at stake here.
In the present day a map
is considered accurate
when the coordinates of the
places, the latitudes as well
as the longitudes, are accurate.
Can we apply this same concept
to a medieval nautical chart
which was not made on the
basis of the latitudes
and longitudes of the places?
If not, what criteria
should we apply
to assess the accuracy
of those charts?
Taking into account the fact that
Portolan Charts were constructed
with the purpose of supporting
navigation the natural way would be
to evaluate to what extent they
would fit to that same purpose.
Let me give another example
taken from a different period.
This is, of course, the
Cantino Planisphere,
drawn by an anonymous
Portuguese cartographer in 1502
and immediately taken to Italy
by an emissary of the Duke
of Fihad [Assumed Spelling],
Alberto Cantino.
The Cantino Planisphere is one
of the most precious monuments
of our cartographic
heritage, depicting the world
as it became known to the European
nations after the great discoveries
of the 15th Century, to
Africa, Newfoundland,
Central America, Brazil and India.
Notice how these regions
are already represented
in their approximate
geographical locations
and how much detail
some of them show.
Also, and following the
introduction of astronomical matters
of navigation during the second half
of the 15th Century this is
the earliest [inaudible] chart
where places were represented
according to their latitudes.
With the Cantino Planisphere a
new cartographical standard was
established, promptly adopted
by many other world maps
of the beginning of
the 16th Century.
Like the Caveri Planisphere
and the two printed world maps
of Martin Waldseemuller engraved
in 1507 and 1516 now kept
in The Library of Congress,
of course.
Once more, the question I would
like to propose regarding these
early nautical Planisphere is the
following, how accurate are they?
Very often historians have tried
to give an answer to this question
by comparing the coastlines
depicted on these maps with those
of modern representations.
If we apply the procedure
to the outline of Africa
in the Cantino Planisphere on the
right by using a satellite image
of the earth as the model on the
left the result is surprising.
Notice how in the old
charts the contour
of the Continent appears
grossly displaced and stretched
into east-west direction, making
the Isthmus of Suez look enormous.
How can we explain this
mistake, which was replicated
in all cartography of the
16th Century and beyond,
including Waldseemuller's
Carta Marina.
Various explanations were
given by the historians.
Some have considered that
the apparent distortion
of Africa is the normal result
of the poor surveying techniques
of the time when longitudes could
not be determined accurately.
Others postulated that the
exaggeration was to the extent
of the Continent was copied
from Ptolemy's geography.
We will see that both
explanations are wrong.
In order to put ourselves
firmly within the navigational
and cartographical
reality of the time
and avoid inaccuranism let us
imagine the following experiment.
Suppose that we take part in the
surveying maritime expedition
in the beginning of the 16th
Century with the purpose
of representing the coast
of Africa on the chart.
Departing from Lisbon the idea is
to sail around the African Continent
up to Cape [inaudible]
keeping the ship as close
to the coast as possible.
All we have available
as navigational instruments is a
magnetic compass to steer the ship
and the nautical astrolight [Assumed
Spelling] to observe the sun
and determine latitude onboard.
We are further requested to keep a
navigational record containing the
courses steered and the latitudes
determined along the route,
as in this table.
After the trip is completed
the next step will consist
in representing graphically
the ship's tracks
on the modern map using the courses
and the latitudes noted
in the ship's log.
The first track in the log is the
one connecting Lisbon to the Island
of Matheta [Assumed Spelling].
The course is approximately
southwest and the latitudes
of Matheta is 32 degrees north.
The second is between
Matheta and the Island
of Timoleaf [Assumed Spelling]
in the Caribbean Islands.
The third between Timoleaf
and [inaudible] Islands and so
on around the southern tip of
Africa and back to Cape [inaudible].
The result is totally
unexpected as it seems
to contradict our direct experience.
The coastline was in sight most of
the time and Cape [inaudible] was,
indeed, reached at
the end of the voyage.
Something went very wrong, but what?
Well, knowing that our experiment
has taken place in the 16th Century
and that we have used an
ordinary magnetic compass
to measure the courses
it is expected
that those directions were
affected by magnetic declination.
If that were not the
case the track recorded
in our log would look
like this, of course.
However, in the beginning
of the 16th Century magnetic
declination had the peculiar special
distribution in the area, it
was east in the Atlantic Ocean
and west in the Indian Ocean.
This made all compass
courses in the Atlantic
to have negative errors
causing the corresponding tracks
to appear rotated counterclockwise.
And all compass courses
in the Indian Ocean
to have positive errors making
the corresponding tracks
to appear rotated clockwise.
This fully explains why the
route that we have to insert
from the ship's log to the
modern map looks distorted.
Thus, can we conclude that
our compass was faulty?
Not really, because it behaved
exactly how it was supposed
to behave.
Although the pilots of the 16th
Century were perfectly aware
of the phenomenon of magnetic
declination no corrections were made
to the courses measured
by the compass.
More importantly, and
this is a critical point
to understand the nautical
cartography of the time,
no corrections were made
to the directions used
to make the very charts.
Thus, it won't come as a
surprise that our track
around the African
Continent, which was determined
with a magnetic compass, almost
exactly matches the coastline
in the Cantino Planisphere.
Now coming back to the initial
question about the accuracy
of this chart, it seems now clear
that once again the usual criterion
of cartography accuracy on
the latitudes and longitudes
of places should not
be applied here.
That was a mistake not only
of the present day historians,
but also of the cosmographers of the
16th Century, as we will see next.
Around 1560 the Portuguese
cartographer, Lopo Homem,
in a note addressed to The
Crown harshly complained
about the new official cartographic
pattern that was enforced
by the [inaudible], the
Mathematician [inaudible].
According to him such a pattern
was prepared using the eclipses
of the sun and moon in order to
show that from Lisbon to India
and to [inaudible] there was
less distances than shown
on the traditional charts.
However, and these are
the words of Lopo Homem,
the charts made according to
the new pattern and I quote,
were so widely distanced from all
truth and navigational science
that many ships had been lost
and the pilots were forced
to buy their charts in Castile.
At the time this letter
was written everybody knew
that the longitudinal distance
between Lisbon and India as shown
in the contemporary
charts was exaggerated.
In a treatise written some 30 years
before the same [inaudible] had
already complained about
the fact which he attributed
to the incompetence of the pilots,
although [inaudible]
was absolutely right
about the exaggerated longitudinal
distance between Lisbon and India,
he was absolutely wrong that
the pilots were to blame.
In 1547 he was appointed
as cosmographer major
becoming responsible
for the royal cartographic pattern.
Then he finally had the opportunity
to correct what he considered
to be a major mistake and so he
did by ordering the longitude
of [inaudible] in India to be
determined by astronomical methods.
The result was a new representation
in which the longitudinal distance
between Lisbon and India
was substantially shortened
as in [inaudible] himself.
Why did the cartographer
consider this model widely distant
from all truth and
navigational science?
What kind of effort would make
a chart so unfit for navigation?
Clearly, he was not
referring to the distances.
Usually not to trust on
the contemporary charts,
but to the orientation
of the coastlines,
which no longer reflected the
compass courses between places.
Who was right and wrong
in this dispute?
He would use scientific methods to
determine the longitude of India
and then forced his interpretation
onto the official cartographer,
Lopo Homem, who complained
directly to The Crown
and supported his position
with practical arguments
concerning the safety of navigation.
The answer to this question
depends on the use of charts.
If they were, indeed, intended
to support navigation
then [inaudible] was wrong
and Lopo Homem was right.
In no way could the two be
reconciliated at the time.
In 1569 Mercator presented
his map of the world
with the revealing title from the
Latin, New and Improved Description
of the Earth Properly Adjusted
for the Use of Navigation.
And in his map meridians and
parallels from a regular mesh
of rectangles where the spacing
between parallels increases
with latitude in such a way that
the [inaudible] lines or lines
of constant course are represented
by straight segments
making the correct angle
with all the meridians.
In theory the solution would
facilitate enormously the planning
and execution of navigation.
But was Mercator's world map
truly adapted to navigation
at the time it was proposed?
As a matter of fact, it was not.
More than 200 years had still
to pass before the novel
perception could be fully adopted
by the pilots, not because the
pilots were conservative or ignorant
but owing to its incompatibility
with the navigational maps
of the time still based on
latitudes and magnetic courses.
Only after the longitude problem
was solved and the distribution
of magnetic declination was known
could the old cartographic model
originated in the Cantino
Planisphere be abandoned for good
and replaced by the
Mercator projection.
But the story is not
over, when we look closely
into the geographical content of
Mercator's world map we realize
that places are not really
represented according
to their latitudes and
longitudes as they should.
If we compared its depiction of
Africa on the right with the one
on Mercator's map on the left
we realize with amazement
that the same old east-west
displacement is still present.
How should we interpret
this unexpected mistake?
The fact is that Mercator
could do no better
than transferring directly the
coastlines of the maps and charts
of this time to the novel
perception with no concern
for their distortions, assuming
wrongly that both the latitudes
and the longitudes of the places
were approximately correct.
Could he have made a better chart?
Not really, in order to construct an
accurate Mercator representation a
new survey was required, this
time based on the latitudes,
the longitudes and the true
direction between places.
As we know, such an endeavor
could only be started
after the longitude problem
was solved near the end
of the 18th Century.
And then coming to the
end of my presentation,
three different navigational
cartographic models were developed
throughout history.
The Portolan Chart based on magnetic
courses and estimated distances.
The Latitude Chart based on
magnetic courses and latitudes.
And the Mercator Chart based
on geographical coordinates
and true [inaudible]
line directions.
Not only were these three models
were designed to support specific
and distinct navigational methods,
but also they were
mutually incompatible.
We know that the content of
nautical charts was routinely used
to construct lavish depictions of
the world to be offered to emperors
and popes and to be
employed by them as symbols
of glory and national power.
At the time, however, none of
those people were aware of the fact
that such representations were not
real maps and that the continents,
the islands and the coastlines were
distorted in weird unsuspected ways.
These distortions were noticed
by the [inaudible] who insisted
to have them corrected,
being systematically opposed
by cartographers and pilots who
invoked the safety of navigation.
Only today can we fully understand
the subtle technical reasons behind
these disputes and conclude, first,
that historically nautical
charts can only be understood
in the context of the navigational
methods they were intended
to support and, second,
that a nautical chart
should not be considered
as a [inaudible] geographical map
but as a diagram to
support navigation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well, we will move
on from nautical charts
to actual navigation.
Our next speaker, Don McGuirk,
is a retired Physician,
has been a map enthusiast
for a very long time.
He has published extensively
in things like Terra Incognita.
He's been a long-term member
of The Phillips Society,
the Washington Map Society, and the
Society of History of Discoveries.
His talk today is going to focus
on the Carta Marina and Columbus.
Don?
[ Applause ]
>> Don McGuirk: Good afternoon.
These lights are bright.
Can you hear me okay like this?
Okay, are my slides up?
Thank you.
So our topic this afternoon will be
how the Waldseemuller Carta Marina
answered perhaps the
great - start again.
[laughter] How the Waldseemuller
Carta Marina answered perhaps the
greatest unsolved cartographic
puzzle of the period.
And this quote was by a friend
of many here in the audience,
Ken Nebanzol [Assumed Spelling].
And what was that great
unsolved cartographic puzzle?
The Northwest Continent
on the Carta Marina.
Now this Northwest Continent
was on several earlier maps
than the Carta Marina,
the Cantino, the Caveri,
the Waldseemuller 1507,
and the Ruysch map.
Now if you look at North
America and you look
at the Carta Marina this certainly
does look like North America.
You can understand how many
people feel very strongly
that this represents the
geography of North America.
It just looks right, but you have to
be careful and I agree 100% with one
of the earlier presenters who
said you've got to be very careful
about what you say
is correct geography
when you look at early maps.
And I'll give you an example
here, so here is North America
and here is a chart
showing some geography.
And I will tell you that this
geography is directly west of Spain
and a little south, and on this
map I believe you can see Cape Cod,
the Peninsula of Florida, the Gulf
of Mexico, the Yucatan Peninsula,
and you can even see the
Mississippi and the Rio Grande.
And yet this is not North America,
this is the Asian coast
on the Fra Mauro map.
So you have to be very careful.
And if you take a close look,
some people might say, well,
maybe it was North America.
Well, this North America, the Gulf
of Mexico actually says the Gulf
of the Ganges, and North America
is populated with a number
of Chinese cities,
so don't think so.
So let's look at the 1507 first.
You can look at both of
them upstairs, if you wish.
And on the 1507 map you notice
that the continent isn't named
and just southeast
of this continent,
the northwest continental landmass,
you see an island named Isabela.
Now, on the other hand, if you go
to the 1516 Waldseemuller
there's been some changes.
Now you can see that the continent
has been named, it's named Cuba,
and Columbus discovered Cuba and
he actually said it's part of Asia,
and that's what this map says.
And if you look at the Island
of Isabela it's no longer named.
Now I think a logical conclusion
might be, it doesn't have to be
but might be that between 1507
and 1516 Waldseemuller or one
of his cohorts discovered
information that suggested to him
that this was Columbus' Cuba,
this giant continental landmass.
Now I understand it seems a
little unlikely, if you will,
that this giant continent
represents the small Island of Cuba,
but there are a number
of individuals
who have held the minority
opinion that it is.
And here's a list of 17 of
those, starting very early.
The most outspoken of
these 17 was George Nunn,
who wrote several articles
on this topic.
And some of the names on this list
are sitting here in the auditorium,
and I can only hope they
haven't changed their minds
since the last time
I talked to them.
So instead of making assumptions
let's create a map using information
contemporary to Columbus' first two
voyages to test the minority opinion
that this northwest
landmass represents Cuba.
So here we are in our Lisbon studios
and we're going to make a map,
and we have found three pieces
of information that are going
to help us make this map.
In other words, recreate what
Columbus said about Cuba.
And those three pieces of
information are, number one,
the Diario or the log of his
first voyage, number two,
a group of letters that Columbus
wrote to the King and Queen of Spain
and we'll just call the
collection the Libro Copiador,
and the third is a
manuscript document written
by a gentleman named
Fernan Perez de Luna
and we'll name is document
Informacion y Testimonio.
So from these three we will exact
the following geographic information
regarding the land that
Columbus named Cuba -
the shape of Columbus' Cuba,
the size of Columbus' Cuba,
the relative position of Columbus'
Cuba with the Island of Isabela
that we've already looked at.
So, first, let's talk about
the shape of Columbus' Cuba.
In letter four of the Libro Copiador
work we read, these coasts run,
and he's talking about the
continental landmass or, I'm sorry,
the Cuba that he's discovering,
these coasts run to the west,
the one trending away from the
Arctic and the other toward it
which begins narrow and widens out
as one proceeds much like the sail
of a lateen rigged caravel.
Well, here's an image of a lateen
sail and here's our Carta Marina.
From Perez de Luna, from his
Informacion y Testimonio,
he says Cuba is shaped like a
triangle and he calls it un giron,
extending from east to west and
the point is in the eastern part.
Here is a picture of a giron
and here's our Carta Marina.
So if we combine these two
descriptions into a sketch map,
because we're going to do a sketch
map before we do the real thing,
Columbus' Cuba might
look something like this.
Second, the size of Columbus'
Cuba, north and south,
let's talk about the
north extent first.
From his log of his first
voyage he says I am distance
from the equatorial line 42 degrees
and again he says the same thing,
I was 42 degrees north
of the equatorial line.
Now you know and I know that there's
no way he could be at that latitude,
but you're in your studio reading
the information that he has written
down and that's what he's saying.
Anyone recognize this memorial?
Plymouth Rock.
Anyone want to guess where
42 degrees north latitude is
on the east coast?
Plymouth, Massachusetts.
But there's more, from the first,
letter one of the Libro Copiador
he said I traveled along the north
shore of Cuba and the northwest
region still lay before me
at least another 50 or 60 leagues.
Now from Plymouth you see
another 50 or 60 leagues northwest
or north you're going to start
seeing signs that read this,
that's how far north he's saying
he thought this Cuba reached.
How about the southern extent?
Well, this is a little bit
trickier, but here at La Isabela,
which is a city, quote-unquote,
on Hispaniola we are more
than 26 degrees above
the equatorial line,
so a little above the
Tropic of Cancer.
Now on a second voyage he comes
back, he leaves Isabela and he goes
on to sail west along the south
coast of Cuba, so the south coast
of his Cuba should be a little
bit above the Tropic of Cancer.
So now a sketch map might look
something like this, Carta Marina.
Okay, returning to the shape
of Columbus' Cuba we have some
more information from da Luna.
He says Cuba - I'm sorry,
Columbus pronounced it
to be continental land,
Asia, by its shape.
This statement by de
Luna strongly suggests
that it was this same shape, a
triangle, that Columbus expected
to find on the coast of Asia
close to the Tropic of Cancer.
Now does this shape occur on
the east coast of Asia on maps
and globes contemporary to Columbus?
Yes, it does.
So here's some images of the
east coast of Asia about the time
of Columbus' sail, the Yale Marteles
[Assumed Spelling] map shows the
peninsula shaped landmass just
north of the Tropic of Cancer.
Here's a better view
of that same geography.
Thank you, Chet, for
allowing me to use this image.
And the Behaim globe also shows
a triangular shaped landmass
on the coast of Asia right
at the Tropic of Cancer.
Waldseemuller, Carta Marina,
Behaim globe, not dissimilar.
So does Columbus believe he has
discovered an anticipated Asian
peninsula or is there
additional information recorded
that he thought he was coasting
this very specific Asian peninsula,
the Mangi peninsula?
Such information is
available, again,
from his log from his first voyage.
While he's on the north shore of
Cuba he states and it is certain
that this is tierra firma,
continental land, and that I am,
he says, off Zayto and Quinsay,
100 leagues more or less
from one and from the other.
Well, let's go back
to our Behaim globe.
Here is Zayto and here is
Quinsay on that very peninsula,
not exactly where they're supposed
to be but on that peninsula.
If we go to the recreated map
from the Toscanali [Assumed
Spelling] letter here's the Mangi
peninsula, here's Zayto - I'm sorry,
here's Quinsay and there's Zayto.
Well, you could ask
the question, well,
did Columbus ever even see
any globes or world maps?
And from this first log we find
out that while discussing Japan
and in the spheres that I saw and in
the world maps it is in this region,
so he's seen both globes
and world maps.
And any of those at
this particular time
in history almost certainly would
have had the Mangi peninsula
that we've already shown.
Well, let's talk a little bit
about this Island of Isabela
and its relationship
to Columbus' Cuba.
From Perez de Luna, Columbus
came to seek the land
of the said Cuba nearest
to the Island of Isabela.
Now this is an important statement,
he calls it the land of Cuba,
not the Island of Cuba, and he says
that Isabela is the
island closest to it.
but Columbus in his log of his
first voyage states that Hispaniola,
Haiti and the Dominican Republic
is the island closest to Cuba.
So now you, as a young
cartographer, have a problem.
There appears to be
a contradiction here.
Two possibilities I would
suggest, either de Luna
or Columbus has renamed
Hispaniola, Isabela,
or there is another
island named Isabela
that is even closer to
Cuba than Hispaniola.
Well, the answer to this question
can be found in both letters to
and letters for the Libro Copiador.
And within those two letters
Columbus uses the name Isabela 15
times when discussing
the Island of Hispaniola.
Columbus has renamed Hispaniola,
Isabela, on his second voyage.
Some additional proof
that this is Isabela,
that Hispaniola is Isabela
is found on this title page
of a book on Marco Polo's travels.
And on this title page about halfway
down on the left-hand side
there's a woodcut of a city
and this information above the city.
Santo Domingo on the
Island of Isabela.
Now if we look at a modern
map of Hispaniola we find
out that Santo Domingo is still
there, it's still the capitol
of the Dominican Republic.
So Santo Domingo was founded
by Bartholomew Columbus in 1496
and it was the first seat of Spanish
colonial rule in the New World,
so it was a very important city.
Now if you understand
that Hispaniola is Isabela then
your maps look something like this,
King Hamy map 1502 Cuba, Isabela,
Maggiolo map of 1511, Cuba, Isabela,
Leonardo da Vinci mappamundi
of 1514, Cuba, Isabela,
Maggiolo Naples 1516, Cuba, Isabela.
Now if you don't understand
that Hispaniola is Isabela then
your maps look something like this,
Cuba, Isabela, Hispaniola.
Waldseemuller 1506, Carta
Marina, Cuba, unnamed Isabela
and Hispaniola, and it might
be that Isabela is now unnamed
because with this additional
information Waldseemuller doesn't
know what to do with that landmass
in between Cuba and Hispaniola.
Several other maps appear
to confirm the hypothesis
that the northwest landmass
represents Columbus' Cuba,
the Ruysch map and the Piri Reis.
Let's start with the Ruysch map
and on this map there is
a continental landmass,
but on this map it's much
smaller than the other maps.
And if you look closely
at this northwest landmass
on the Ruysch you will see
that it wasn't the first
geography on this part of the map.
If you look very closely you can see
that before the triangular landmass
was there was another geography
there that has been pounded
out of the brass plate
or copper plate and
has been replaced.
And if you look very
carefully it says to Cuba.
And here is a recreation of
I assume it was isla to Cuba,
it might have been tierra to Cuba,
but I assume it was isla to Cuba,
that was there before
the triangular landmass.
Now there are some
historians who claim
that Ruysch forgot to
put Cuba on his map.
Well, this erasure proves that
there's no way that happened,
he just chose to use the triangular
shaped landmass to represent Cuba.
I want you to look quickly
at this toponym [inaudible]
and we'll come back to
that in just a little bit.
How about the Piri Reis map of 1513?
And I might need to thank Greg
McIntosh [Assumed Spelling]
for giving me this slide because
what he's done is translated some
of the toponyms into Spanish.
And you can see at the
top it says this is Asia
and Asia is labeled Cuba.
There are two place names or
toponyms on this map, Puerto Grande
and Punta de Hornofay, both names
that Columbus used while he was
discovering the south coast of Cuba.
And to the east Hispaniola, looking
a lot like Japan on early maps,
and the first, quote, city, end
quote, of the New World Navidad.
So this would suggest that
the mainland was Cuba.
So what are the other toponyms
on the continental landmass?
If this continental
landmass is meant
to represent Columbus'
Cuba the toponyms
of this continent should
be associated
with his exploration of Cuba.
There is one place name
in particular that we want
to take a look at and
that's Cavo doffim de abul,
Cape of the end of April.
Now this toponym strongly
suggests that the explorer
of this landmass discovers an
eastern cape on this continent
on April 30th, makes sense.
And here we have that same
toponym on the Waldseemuller 1507
with the Island of Isabela.
No less than the great
historian, Henry Harrisse,
declared this toponym could
not possibly be associated
with Columbus.
Those quotations prove conclusively
that the inscription Cape at the end
of the April has nothing
whatever to do with the Island
of Cuba or any part thereof.
Well, let's test Harrisse's
assertion.
From the Libro Copiador,
letter four,
on April 30th I reached Cabo alpha
et omega, the easternmost cape
of Cuba are also called Cabo Maisi,
and I sailed west along the
southern coast of Cuba as far
as the port I called Grande.
And here's a map of the east end of
Cuba and here's Cabo Maisi defined
by Punta Maisi and Punta
Camato [Assumed Spelling].
And to the far left of the map
Biea Guantanamo [Assumed Spelling],
the Bay of Guantanamo.
So on April 30th Columbus
sailed from Maisi all the way
to Guantanamo, and look at the
geography in between, okay?
Returning to Columbus'
log of his first voyage
on 5 December 1492 he departs
from Cuba on his way to Hispaniola
and he says, that one
passed Cabo Maisi,
he saw that the coast turned
south and trended southwest
and he soon saw a handsome and
high cape in the same direction
and it was distant from the other
one, Cabo Maisi, seven leagues.
In other words, about 18
nautical miles from southwest
of Cabo Maisi there was
a handsome and high cape.
Well, let's go back to our geography
here of east Cuba, Cabo Maisi,
Guantanamo Bay, and here
is another cape defined
by Punta Negra and Punta Caleta.
This is the handsome and high cape.
And if you look at a map of Cuba
showing elevations you can see
that Cabo Maisi is very shallow
or very low lying, whereas,
the southwest cape is quite high.
So here we have a photograph
of Cabo Maisi
and you can see that it's very flat.
And if you look to the far left
skyline you can see what appears
to be a high cape, right there.
And if you take a photograph
from the road on that cape
and looking back at Cabo Maisi
you can see how shallow it is,
how flat it is.
So now we get to the question,
this is the Caveri world map
and outlined here is the
Cape of the end of April.
Now I would ask you does
that toponym name Cabo Maisi,
which many historians
have thought was the case,
or instead does it really
represent the handsome and high cape
to the southwest that he passed
and perhaps named or someone
in his entourage named
Cape of the end of April?
I would suggest the latter
is probably more likely.
There are other toponyms on
this landmass that appear
to support Columbus'
exploration of this landmass,
and I will go through
three of them quickly.
First, Costa Alta, now this toponym
is very difficult for people who say
that this continental landmass
represents North America
because there are no high
coasts in the southeast coast
of North America, there
are just none.
On the other hand, on arriving
at Cuba on October 28th,
1492 he says all this land is high,
uses the word alta, like Sicily.
And here is an image of the coast of
Sicily and here is an image of Cuba
at about the same place that
Columbus first arrived at Cuba.
Las Cabras, the goats, now this has
to be or very likely a misspelling,
which happens a lot on these
early maps for the toponyms,
because there were no goats in the
New World and Columbus says that.
So I would suggest to you that this
toponym was originally Las Abras,
literally translated, the opens.
And on his first forage Columbus
used the term abras twice while
sailing the north coast and in
each case Columbus was referring
to an opening to the
sea between mountains.
And here is an image of what
that geography would look like.
Finally, Rio de las Almadias,
River of the Dugouts.
In Columbus' log of his first
voyage he uses the word almadia
or almadias 24 times when referring
to the vessels of the natives.
And specifically on November 1st he
says more than 16 dugouts, almadias,
came to the ship and
the river that he was
in was very deep, Rio
de las Almadias.
And so these four toponyms match
very well with Columbus' voyage
to Cuba and also matches
the placement
of Spanish flags noting a
discovery for the King and Queen
of Spain displayed on
both Waldseemuller maps.
To review information from Columbus'
exploration of Cuba matches well
with the shape of the
northwest landmass,
the size of the northwest landmass,
the position of the northwest
landmass with respect to the Island
of Isabela, and matches
the toponyms reviewed,
especially the toponym Cape of the
end of April at the eastern end
or the northwest landmass.
Hopefully, the above information
may have convinced you of the fact,
not fiction, that the
northwest landmass depicted
on the Waldseemuller Carta Marina
and other early world maps
is representative of Cuba,
a/k/a Columbus' Asia, what Taviana
[Assumed Spelling] called Columbus'
erroneous opinion of reality.
If it has I'm sure Columbus
would be quite pleased.
Thank you for your kind attention.
I'll be happy to answer
questions later.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well, our
next speaker, Chet Van Duzer,
needs no introduction to this
audience for the most part.
Chet has been studying
the Waldseemuller maps
for many, many years.
I first knew of Chet probably a
decade ago when he gave a talk
at the first Waldseemuller
conference.
He was recommended to me by
someone who had seen him give a talk
on the subject in Europe and
I had never heard of him.
Most people in cartographic circles
at that point had never heard
of him, but he has made
a significant impact
on the discipline now.
Chet and I were Kluge
fellows together and we worked
on a book together on
the Waldseemuller maps,
and during that period
of time we kind
of outlined what we thought were
the central research problems
that were still left in
Waldseemuller scholarship.
During that period I felt a little
bit like, there's a book actually
by the novelist Thomas Bernhard,
which details the exploits
of a pianist who winds up
accidently being in a piano class
with Glenn Gould and he decides
at that point that he needs
to relegate all of the playing
of the piano to Glenn Gould.
At the time I was a Kluge
fellow, I realized that I needed
to relegate all of
the possible solutions
to the Waldseemuller
questions to Chet,
and that is what I have
assigned him tonight, so.
[ Applause ]
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well,
that's a lot to live up to.
Thank you, John, and
thanks to The Library
for organizing this conference.
And I'd also like to thank
the Kislak Foundation
for bringing the Carta Marina to
The Library of Congress and also
for funding the fellowship
through which I had the opportunity
to spend a lot of time
studying the map.
Here it is, as the title of
my talk indicated I'm going
to address two particular
aspects of the map this afternoon.
The first is the originality of the
Carta Marina, both as a departure
from the 1507 map, so I'm going
to contrast it with the 1507 map,
and also as an independent
creation, look at all the work
by Waldseemuller that
went into its creation.
And then also we'll look at the
diffusion of the Carta Marina.
So it's ben claimed that
the one surviving copy,
which is here in The Library
of Congress, is a proof
and that the map did not circulate,
and I hope to provide some evidence
to show that that's not the case,
that it did in fact circulate.
So beginning with the
originality of the Carta Marina
versus the 1507 world map, so again
the Carta Marina is a departure
from the 1507 world map.
The 1507 map is based
on Ptolemy's geography.
Here's the map, I think we're
all familiar with it by now.
He proclaims his debt
to Ptolemy in its title,
A Map of the Whole World According
to the Tradition of Ptolemy
and the Explorations of
Amerigo Vespucci and Others.
As we perhaps, most
of us know at the top
of the map there are portraits
of Ptolemy and Vespucci,
indicating his debt to both of
them, Ptolemy is on the left there.
Here is a Ptolemaic world map, just
so we can know what we're talking
about when we talk
about a debt to Ptolemy.
And just orient ourselves briefly.
Here's Europe, North Africa,
the Arabian Peninsula
and the Indian Ocean.
And, in fact, the 1507 map
is based on a particular map,
which is also based on
Ptolemy, namely the world map
by Henricus Martellus at Yale,
which was made in about 1491.
And just to look at this process
of movement from, if you will,
from Ptolemy through
Martellus to Waldseemuller,
we can see that Martellus
has expanded the area
of the world depicted on his
map with respect to Ptolemy.
So he shows the southern part of
Africa, which Ptolemy does not show.
He extends this geography all
the way to the North Pole,
which Ptolemy did not do, and he
shows not only the eastern coast
of Asia but further out to the
east, all the way to Japan.
So instead of showing 180
degrees of longitude he shows 270,
so a substantial expansion
of the part
of the earth's surface depicted.
If we compare the Martellus world
map and Waldseemuller's world map,
of course, the main difference
is the addition of the New World
and also Waldseemuller very boldly
on his 1507 map portrays
all 360 degrees
of the earth's circumference.
These two maps are very similar
and the similarities were noted
when the Martellus map surfaced
in Bern in the late 1950s.
They are of similar dimensions,
both cartographers take advantage
of the lower margins to
include large text blocks.
The depictions of North
Africa are very similar,
that's not too surprising as both
are based on Ptolemy's geography,
but the depiction of eastern
Asia on the two maps is very -
the similarity of the
depiction of eastern Asia
on the two maps is
very striking, indeed.
As a couple speakers
mentioned earlier,
Marco Polo does not give
latitudes and longitudes,
and on both maps eastern
Asia is based on Marco Polo.
And it's supremely unlikely that
two people would extrapolate Marco
Polo's data so similarly
when Marco Polo says
such city X is 15 days' journey west
of city Y, that leaves a lot of room
for interpretation and it's very
unlikely two cartographers would
interpret that information
similarly.
So we can see some dependence here,
and both cartographers also
placed the Island of Japan
at the eastern edge of the map.
So in other work I've shown
an even close relationship
between the Martellus map
and Waldseemuller's 1507 map.
I don't have time to go
into those details today,
but I would like to look at the
part of Waldseemuller's 1507 map
that does not come from
Martellus, which is the New World.
And what Waldseemuller did is
took the New World from the chart
of Caverio and adjusted that data
to the Ptolemaic projection
he was using.
So what I'm saying, to
sum up a little bit,
is the 1507 map is
basically information
from two maps joined into one.
So it's the Yale Martellus
map, information from that map,
and the depiction of the New
World taken from Caverio's chart.
So the Carta Marina, moving on
to the issue of originality,
is based on an entirely
different cartographic system.
So in the course of nine
years Waldseemuller decided
that the Ptolemaic system was
not the best system to use
in representing the world.
He chose instead to use
nautical chart cartography,
so an entirely different
cartographic foundation.
Here, again, is the Carta Marina.
And he proclaims this
difference in the title,
it's called a nautical chart
that comprehensively shows the
Portuguese voyages in the shape
of the whole known world,
its regions and its limits
as they have been determined in
our times, and how they differ
from the tradition of the Ancients
and also areas not
mentioned by the Ancients.
So it's very clear that he's setting
aside Ancient cartography here
and I think we can
read into that Ptolemy,
he is setting Ptolemy aside.
So he says it's based on
nautical charts and, in fact,
we know which nautical
chart it's based on,
it's based on the Caverio chart.
That's a bold claim, how can we know
that he had this specific
chart in his workshop?
In fact, if one looks at some of
the place names they're copied
from this chart, even down to
spelling errors and corrections.
And if we compare the
two charts we can see
that what Waldseemuller has done
in implementing this new
cartographic system is follow the
outlines of the Caverio
chart very closely.
So the outlines and position of
Greenland are just about identical,
the Island of Pseudo-Labrador
just about identical,
the coast of South America very
similar, the non-Ptolemaic shape
and central location of Africa.
These two south Asian peninsulas
are just about identical in outline,
and the nodes of the rhumb line
network, a characteristic feature
of nautical charts, are in
identical positions on the two maps.
So we can see this outline, he's
copied the outlines and format
of this chart, this
nautical chart very closely.
So in making a world map
based not on Ptolemy,
but rather on nautical
charts he's set aside one
of the figureheads of
his 1507 world map.
As we heard earlier from Don,
in the Carta Marina he follows
Columbus' thought quite closely,
and on the 1507 map he names the
New World after Amerigo Vespucci.
As Don said, the name America does
not appear on the Carta Marina,
so he's come to realize that
Columbus' role in the discovery
of the New World was very important
and so he set aside
Vespucci, as well.
So in the course of nine years
he's set aside the two figureheads
of his 1507 map and this is,
again, a really powerful indication
of how far he had come in these
nine years and what a departure
from the 1507 map the
Carta Marina is.
While I have said that the
Carta Marina is original,
but I've just shown that
he followed the outlines
of Caverio chart very closely,
so how is the map original?
If we zoom in a little
bit we can see
that on the Caverio
chart there's really just
about zero geographical
detail in the interior.
I'm now going to switch to exactly
the same part of the Carta Marina.
There's geographical
detail everywhere,
and that's where the originality
of the Carta Marina resides.
He took the outlines from Caverio's
chart, but all this information,
all these details he's filled in
was the fruit of his own research.
And, as you can see, I'll switch
between those images again, Caverio
and the Carta Marina, it is a very
rich collection of information.
And, again, this is where
the originality resides.
So let's look at where he
gathered some of that information.
Looking at the whole chart, there's
a large text block in the lower left
in which Waldseemuller goes
through some of his sources,
lists some of his sources.
And what I'm going to do now, so
he tells us where he took some
of the information, he doesn't tell
us everything, but what I'm going
to go through and show
is which parts
of the map come from which sources.
So one of the sources that
he mentions is Marco Polo,
the famous Venetian traveler of the
13th Century, who left descriptions
of the Middle East, Central
Asia, China and the Indian Ocean.
On the 1507 map all of
the eastern Asian part
of the map came from Marco Polo.
The situation on the Carta
Marina is very different,
there's just a few sparse legends,
which I've indicated with red dots,
that come from Marco Polo and
this is another indication
of the radical departure that the
Carta Marina is from the 1507 map,
a completely different
use of sources.
One of his other sources
was John of Plano Carpini,
who as a Papal Legate
took a northern route
to go see the Great Khan
in the 13th Century.
It's unlikely that - I'm sorry, here
we have - there's a problem here.
Yes, so I'm sorry, here
are the legends that come
from John of Plano Carpini.
It's likely that Waldseemuller
took this information not directly
from Plano Carpini, but rather
by excerpts from Plano Carpini
that appear in Vincent of Beauvais.
There are very few manuscripts
of Plano Carpini's work.
There are many more manuscripts
of Vincent of Beauvais
and his book was published
in Strasbourg in 1473,
so it's a much more
readily available source
for the same information.
Another of his sources was Odoric
of Pordenone, an Italian missionary
and diplomat who traveled to
China in the early 14th Century.
And here I show a map of the
places visited by Odoric,
and what we'll see that
you can see clearly
that the places he
visited are southern Asia.
When we look at the texts on
the Carta Marina that come
from Odoric we can see that
they are not in southern Asia,
and what we are to conclude is that
Waldseemuller had a better source
for southern Asia, a more
recent source so that
in southern Asia rather than
use Odoric, whom he did use
for some information, he
chose a more recent source
who we'll get to later.
Another of his sources was Pierre
d'Ailly, a French Cardinal,
theologian and cosmographer
who wrote a book called
the Amago mundi in 1410.
Waldseemuller used that book
as a source for his description
of the Caspian Sea and also for
some of the monstrous races in India
and I'll zoom in here and
show some of the illustrations
of those monstrous peoples.
Another of his important sources
was a book called Paesi novemente
retrovati or Newly
Discovered Countries,
a collection of travel narratives
that was first published
in Italy in 1507.
One of the works in that
book was the travel narrative
of Alvise Cadamosto, a
Venetian merchant and navigator
who explored the western
coast of Africa for Portugal
in the middle of the 15th Century.
And, as we would expect,
the text from Cadamosto are
on the western coast of Africa.
Another source that appears in
that same book is the narrative
of Joseph the Indian or Priest
Joseph, a Christian priest
from India who sailed
back to Portugal
with Cabral [Assumed Spelling],
and I've highlighted the texts
that come from Joseph the Priest.
One of those is the description of
Calicut that's included on the map,
the long text block there.
The same book, the Paesi novamente
retravate [Assumed Spelling],
was the source of a large text
block in the lower right-hand corner
of the map that goes through
the prices and sources
of spices available in Calicut.
And I think that text is
very interesting in terms
of indicating the practical
orientation of the Carta Marina.
Another of his really crucial
sources was Ludovico de Varthema,
the Italian traveler and a keen
observer who visited Egypt,
the Middle East, India and the
Islands of the Indian Ocean early
in the 15th [Assumed
Spelling] Century.
His narrative appears in the
Paesi novamente retravate,
but I'm quite confident that the
edition, well at least one edition
of the work that Varthema consulted
was this illustrated edition
of 1515.
We can see here the long texts on
the map that come from Varthema,
and we see that they are
concentrated in southern Asia
and this gives us a hint as to why
Waldseemuller did not use much text
from Odoric because he had
a better, more recent source
of information in southern Asia.
So in addition to looking at
the sources of some of the text
on the Carta Marina,
I'd like to look at some
of the sources of images.
So, again, looking at the
originality of the map,
looking at the research
that Waldseemuller, himself,
did to compile the information
that appears in the map.
This is the image of
Mecca on the Carta Marina.
It comes from precisely that
1515 edition of Varthema
that I mentioned earlier.
You can see the strong
similarity of the buildings.
And, again, the book was published
just one year before the Carta
Marina was printed so Waldseemuller
was using the most recent sources
available to him.
This image of suttee in India, the
practice whereby a wife was supposed
to join her husband on
his funeral pyre, again,
comes from the same book, the
illustrated edition of Varthema.
One clue that confirms that
is the presence of this demon
in the two illustrations.
Here's a rhinoceros
on the Carta Marina.
We're all familiar with the 1515
Dur [Assumed Spelling] illustration
of the rhinoceros, some
little details indicate
that his source was rather
Burgkmair's print of the rhinoceros,
which was also printed in 1515.
I'll just put them
side-by-side there.
So, again, making use of not
only the most recent text,
but also the most recent
illustrations.
And looking now at the southern part
of the Carta Marina there's
a wonderful illustration
of King Manuel riding a sea monster
and this proclaims visually
a symbolic indication
of Portuguese control
of the sea route
around Africa from Portugal to Asia.
And the source of that image I
suspect was Jacopo de' Barbari's
View of Venice, where if we zoom
in a little bit we have
Neptune riding a sea monster
as protector of Venice.
But there's an additional
significance to the image
of King Manuel that I
want to touch upon here.
If we go back to Waldseemuller's
1507 map there are texts
about sea monsters, there are
no images, and the texts come
from medieval sources and they're
the sort of thing one would expect,
they don't indicate - they indicate
that the ocean is a
dangerous place to travel.
This image is entirely different,
it proclaims human control
of sea monsters and, thus, symbolic
human domination of the seas.
And I would suggest that this
contrast suggests a change
in Waldseemuller's conception of
the ocean from a place of danger
to a place across which
human trade can be conducted.
And in, again, just nine years
that's a remarkable shift.
So that's what I have to say about
the originality of the Carta Marina.
I want to move on to the
fusion of the Carta Marina
and this suggestion, which
was made by Joseph Fisher,
that the map did not circulate,
that the one surviving copy that was
in the Schoner Sambelband [Assumed
Spelling] that is now at The Library
of Congress was a proof sheet.
And one argument in favor
of that understanding is
that there is only
one copy of the map,
why is it that we have
only one copy?
And the same question holds
true for the 1507 map?
But, in fact, that's a very common
condition of 16th Century maps.
So I've compiled a little list here
of 16th Century maps that survive
in either 01 or 02 exemplars.
So Giovani Contarini, Waldseemuller
owned 1511 Carta intineraria,
Rosselli's printed nautical chart.
You can read through the list.
This list was very easy to compile
and makes no pretense
at completeness.
It's very common that 16th
Century printed maps survive in 01
or 02 exemplars, and
just to continue to list
through the end of the century.
Again, I could have made
this list much longer.
So even some copies of
the Carta Marina printed
by Lorenz Fries survive
in 01 or again 1 exemplar.
It's a very common condition, so
I don't think that can be taken
as any evidence whatsoever that
the Carta Marina did not circulate.
Well, what about providing some
evidence that it did circulate?
Well, the Carta Marina was used
as a model for Lorenz Fries' maps
of 1525, 1530 and 1531, so three
different editions, reprintings,
if you will, with some
modifications of the Carta Marina.
There's no exemplar of the
1525 edition that survives.
We can look and compare one sheet
of the Waldseemuller 1515 map
with the 1530 edition by Fries,
we can see they're very similar.
So Fries went to the trouble
of printing another edition
of the Carta Marina, and it
strikes me as supremely unlikely
that he was using the one copy
that was also preserved
by Johannes Schoner.
And just to show there's
only one surviving exemplar
of the 1531 edition by Fries,
again, I think the fact
that the map was seen
as popular enough
to reproduce this way
indicates that there was more
than just the one copy
that's come down to us.
We can also see some interesting
hints of the availability
of Waldseemuller's Carta
Marina to Norman cartographers
at the middle of the 16th Century.
So if we look at eastern Africa
and the Arabian Peninsula
and the Vallard Atlas of 1547,
which is in the Huntington Library
in California, and we zoom in on
the Arabian Peninsula here is what's
probably Mecca in that chart
and it is very similar, indeed,
to Mecca on Waldseemuller's
Carta Marina.
And I want to point out the crescent
at the top of both buildings,
so we know that Waldseemuller took
his image from the image of Medina
in the 15 edition of
Varthema, is it possible
that that image was rather the
source for the Vallard Atlas?
But given that it does
not have the crescent
at the top I think the answer is no.
And is it possible that the source
was rather the image of Mecca
from one of Fries'
reprintings of the Carta Marina?
And, again, I think
the answer is no.
The image of Mecca in the
Vallard Atlas is more complex
architecturally than the
image in Fries' Carta Marina.
So I think Waldseemuller's Carta
Marina is the only plausible source
for this image and this indicates
the map had circulated to France.
Looking at another similar example,
this is Pierre Desceliers' 1546
world map at John Rylands Library,
and I want to zoom in on the
image of suttee in India.
Here it is, the image is a
bit indistinct so this piece
of evidence is not as strong
I think as that of Mecca,
but I want to point out we can see
the woman in the fire raising one
of her arms and we now have
multiple other sources,
potential sources to compare.
So here's the image of suttee in the
1515 Varthema, it doesn't strike me
as a very close correspondence,
the woman is facing the other way,
is raising her other
arm, for example.
Here's the image on
the Carta Marina,
Waldseemuller's Carta Marina, again,
I think this image is much closer,
there's just two people around the
woman, she's raising the same arm,
her attitude seems very similar.
Here is the image on Fries' copy
of Waldseemuller's Carta Marina,
the woman's attitude
is quite different,
her arm is down instead of up.
And, finally, the image in the
1522 Ptolemy, which was also based
on Waldseemuller's Carta Marina
and the image here is
entirely different.
So really the image on
Waldseemuller's Carta Marina seems
like the most plausible source for
the image on the 1546 map and, thus,
further evidence that the
Carta Marina was available
to Norman cartographers.
One more Norman example, here's
Pierre Desceliers' 1550 world map.
We zoom in on North America, this is
a representation of Roberval's Fort
in Canada and it's familiar.
It seems to have been copied
from the image of Mecca
on Waldseemuller's Carta Marina.
And we can go through again, I
want to highlight the presence
of the buttresses there, and we
can go through the other candidates
and I think it's fair to say, again
it's not completely solid evidence,
but I think it's fair to say that
Desceliers' image most likely comes
from Waldseemuller's Carta
Marina and not from any
of the derivative images
of the city.
And one more piece of evidence
that the Carta Marina
did circulate appears
in Abraham Ortelius' the
Theatrum orbis terrarum,
first printed in 1570.
Ortelius includes in the
work a catalog of his sources
and I've showed the first
page of that catalog here.
And zooming in on this
entry we can see
that he cites Martin Waldseemuller,
universal navigation chart,
which many call a marine
chart, published in Germany,
and he adds that he thinks
this Waldseemuller is the same
as the aforementioned ilacomylus,
which is Waldseemuller's
Latin pen name.
So Ortelius cites the Carta
Marina as one of his sources,
that proves that the chart
did, in fact, circulate.
So a few conclusions.
I think the development in
Waldseemuller's cartographic thought
in the course of nine years is
something that's really remarkable
and the originality and
all the work that went
into the Carta Marina is
also quite impressive.
The combination of research,
of not only textual sources
in a substantial library of
contemporary geographical thought,
but also research for images, not
only in texts, in printed books,
but also in other maps
is quite impressive.
And, again, I think I've been able
to show, I hope I've been able
to show that the map did, indeed,
circulate, that it was not confined
to the single copy
that's come down to us.
What we have was not
maybe a proof copy,
but the map had a broader printing
history and it did circulate.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: If the
speakers want to come
up we can take some questions?
Are there any questions?
>> This is for Chet Van Duzer.
What's remarkable about the 1507 map
is the presence of the Pacific Ocean
and a well-defined west coast of
South America, but the 1516 map,
which is a nautical
chart, lacks that.
So how do you explain that omission
and the fact if it's designed
for sailors it doesn't
have what he knew in 1507?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes, I would say
that it's not actually an omission,
it's a reflection of a
difference in intended audience
and purpose for the two maps.
So the Carta Marina in general
depicts less of the earth's surface,
not only in the West but
in all its other corridors.
And I think that Waldseemuller
decided to make a more practical
and less theoretical map, one
that showed the parts of the earth
that people were actually visiting
or that there was an
immediate prospect of visiting
and also a greater emphasis on
where trade was being conducted.
Hence, I think the long list of
spices with their prices and sources
in the lower right-hand corner
of the map is a strong indicator
of what I see as a greater interest
on practicality of the Carta Marina.
So, again, I think the fact that he
doesn't try to show the West coast
of the New World is sort of a frank
admission that he doesn't know
about it and trying to create
a world map that focuses more
on practical matters, I would say.
>> Don McGuirk: I'd
like to add that on
that far Pacific coast
there is a notation
that says beyond here is unknown,
so it doesn't necessarily mean
that that's the West coast,
the cartographer just
doesn't know whether beyond
that there is land
or sea or whatever.
So if you take a close
look that notation is there
and that may very well
be what he means,
he doesn't know what's beyond here.
>> John Hessler: Bill?
>> Yes, my question is for Chet,
but I'd be interested if any
of the other speakers
have any opinion.
What is your speculation as to why
there are only zero or one or two
of so many important maps that
presumably were relatively expensive
and required a great
deal of effort to produce
and have essentially disappeared?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Wall maps, in
particular, don't survive well.
So not for Waldseemuller's
Carta Marina
but for the Fries' re-editions, if
you will, they came with a pamphlet
that has instructions for
pasting the sheets onto the wall.
So one pastes the sheets onto the
wall and 15 years later or less
or more, it doesn't matter, but
one remodels and the map goes away.
And so the only reason the Carta
Marina has come down to us was
because it was preserved
in a different way,
placed into a codex
by Johannes Schoner.
Not all the maps I listed were wall
maps, a large portion of them were.
They were all large, I believe,
and large maps in general,
aside from the question
of pasting them to walls,
just don't survive well, yes.
>> John Hessler: You can also
bring that up-to-date today,
a map is only as good as sort
of the modern information
that kind of flows into it.
Without some historical sense
that we need to keep these
for historical purposes
they quickly became obsolete
and probably used to start the fire.
So it's just like now, a
1972 roadmap, who cares?
So I think a lot of it has to
do with just the obsolescence
of the information on them.
You know, Schoner had a different
purpose, he used those maps
for probably astrological purposes
as opposed to geographical purposes
and he basically tells
us in his bookplate
that he was saving
them for posterity.
So he very well knew what he was
doing with them, so without a bunch
of Schoners around it's, you
know, they just go to the wind.
>> I think that's an
interesting discussion,
but unfortunately we
also have information
that suggested a thousand copies
of the 1507 map were produced.
That's a huge number to be destroyed
indiscriminately it seems to me.
>> John Hessler: Assuming
you take him at his word.
And what cartographer
doesn't lie or perhaps blow it
out of proportion what he was doing?
And even on that text block we're
not really sure exactly what he's
referring to, you know, was he
referring to the 1513 Ptolemy,
a thousand copies of the
maps that were in there,
you know, that sort of thing?
The bigger questions with this map
that we didn't touch on, at all,
and maybe Chet will touch
on a little bit of work
that we had started doing,
is we don't know where either
of these maps were printed.
We don't know who did
the wood blocks.
There's lots of mysterious
things doing
with the type faces on the map.
These look like they weren't
these small little projects
that we have imagined them to be.
This little teeny group
of cartographers
in Santiae [Assumed Spelling]
working away on these maps.
Just the sources that Chet has
identified, and that's only a few
of the many, many, many, many
other sources that he pointed out,
the access to this information had
to be someplace else
besides this little village.
And so if you want to
say a little something
about the type face research,
just to show the kind
of big project this was?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well, when
I was at The Library working
on my fellowship and John
was right across from me
in The Kluge Center we got
started looking at the type faces
and there are implications for
where the maps were printed,
but I don't think we were
able to really take it
as far as we should have.
>> John Hessler: No, we weren't,
but it turned out that there were
some 22 different printer type faces
on that map.
In other words, the type
faces are usually associated
with a single printer at this time
and there's 22 different type faces
associated with different printers
that appear on the Carta Marina.
And then there was some symbology
that was also somewhat strange,
there's a backslash which we could
only find used by one printer
who didn't really seem to have
anything to do with this group.
So there's a lot of mystery
about these two maps.
For me there are always going
to be these bizarre perfect
filogical [Assumed Spelling]
objects, there's just
enough information to kind
of grasp both the scholars
and the crazies who think
that it was ancient aliens.
But when you start looking
at it just the sand just goes
through your hands and
it's very frustrating.
Any other - Wes?
>> This one is at least,
first, for Dr. McGuirk.
When you look at the place names on
what at first looks like Florida,
but you're arguing is Cuba or
at least as thought by Columbus,
do any of the place names there line
up with any of these Asian sources
that Chet talked about or are they
all following Columbus' records
of his voyage?
Because you only hit
a few place names,
but there's an awful lot there.
>> Don McGuirk: No, I think, and
I don't know if Chet has looked
at this or not, but I think
the first, the northern three
or four are probably either
from Marco Polo or from voyages
by the English or maybe
even Portuguese [inaudible].
You get to a certain point
and it lines up very well
with Columbus but, no, my
thought was that the top three
or four were probably Portuguese
or English or even Marco Polo.
There's one that I'm
pretty sure was Marco Polo.
>> Chet Van Duzer: I
haven't looked at them,
but that would certainly
be a lot of fun.
>> John Hessler: Ben?
>> You showed how the distortion
of Africa is from the problem
of using the magnetic
declination, so when you look
at those maps Brazil
is also very distorted,
so do you think you could apply the
same analysis to the distortions
of Brazil to explain
them on those maps?
>> Joaquim Gaspar: I'm not
sure I understood perfectly.
You are talking about the
misrepresentation of Brazil
or the misplacement of Brazil?
>> And misplaced.
>> Joaquim Gaspar: And stretched?
>> And stretched.
So do you think if you did that
same kind of nice analysis you did
to explain that for Africa, you
could also do the same for Brazil?
>> Joaquim Gaspar: Yes, absolutely.
Well, there was a Portuguese
nobleman who made the voyage
to Brazil, is called [inaudible].
He was also a viceroy of India
during the middle 16th Century.
He explained in detail, it's
amazing his explanation,
the reason for the misplacement
and the stretching and Africa
and the misplacement of Brazil.
He interprets correctly that was
the affect of magnetic declination
on the [inaudible]
measures by the pilots
and transferred directly
to the charts.
That happens exactly with
Brazil, Brazil is closer to Lisbon
than it should be because of
magnetic declination, yes.
Not only Brazil, but Newfoundland.
>> This is a question
for Chet or any of you.
obviously, all of these
maps are coming
out of the European Christian
tradition, but Chet showed a number
of these representations
of the Caba and Mecca
and literally the Islamic passion
for calculating correctly the qibla
from anywhere in the world,
latitude and longitude,
to point towards that,
is there any evidence
for Islamic sources connected
with the qibla feeding
into this grand plan in any way?
>> Chet Van Duzer: I
would have to say, no.
There's a tradition in nautical
charts of representing the tomb
of Muhammad as floating in
the air and it was believed,
the texts on the nautical charts
indicate that Muslims went to Mecca
to worship the tomb of Muhammad,
which of course is not in Mecca.
So I would think that if any
information had been flowing
from Islamic sources about Mecca
they certainly would not have made
that mistake.
In fact, Varthema, the one traveler
that Waldseemuller
may have had a use
of was the first European I believe
to have visited Mecca
and written about it.
So if you're interested in the
history of European knowledge
of Mecca Varthema would be
a good source to consult.
>> John Hessler: Les, go ahead?
>> Yes, this is for Mr. Gaspar.
The question is with respect to
the magnetic declinations off
of the coasts of Africa what
was - did you measure what
that declination would
be based upon, you know,
your analysis of those areas?
>> Joaquim Gaspar: We have two
sources, one historical source,
which is the [inaudible]
has just mentioned
in 1538 from Lisbon to Indian.
It is the first known
exact observations
of magnetic declination.
It's about 40 or 50 [inaudible].
Those were my preferred values
for making the calculations,
but we have other sources which are
not historical which are the outputs
of more than geomagnetic models that
are based on the few measurements
of old values of magnetic
declination.
They measure it on the lava flows
and all the sedimentary
deposits in lakes, et cetera.
And I would say they are very
accurate, but they are accurate
within two, three or four degrees.
So my modeling was based
on these two sources.
But you asked something about the
values of magnetic declination.
Well, we have a hint, we
have a historical hint,
which is the name given to a Gulf
in the Cantino Planisphere near
the very southern tip of Africa,
Gulf desgulish [Assumed
Spelling], Gulf of the Needles,
that was the place where the
magnetic needle pointed exactly
to the north.
We are absolutely sure about
that because several sources
at the time referred to it.
And we also know from
[inaudible] that the values
of magnetic declination
in the Atlantic,
in the south Atlantic
were very high,
up to more than 20 degrees eastward.
And that on the other side in
the Indian Ocean they reach
about 15 degrees west, the
maximum value in the Indian Ocean,
and about 20 or 22 degrees in
the eastern side in the Atlantic,
and about zero in the
Cape of Good Hope.
>> Mr. Gaspar, how do you
reconcile when you go all the way
around Africa and you
are in the Red Sea,
which is beautifully colored red,
the Portuguese makes its entry
so that you have this distortion,
you refer to the declination
of the magnetic needle.
However, when the Portuguese
make it into the Gulf of Suez
or into the area of
Suez and depicting it
on the map far distorted
to the east, however,
knowing that Alexandria
[inaudible] and other places
in the Mediterranean are far
more west, didn't they discover
that on a short distance which was
known to them already in the time
that it couldn't be such a long
stretch or didn't it occur to them?
I'm just curious.
>> Joaquim Gaspar: You had the
microphone to close your mouth,
so I couldn't understand the words.
I'm sorry.
>> Okay, the short version
is the Red Sea was navigated
by the Portuguese, as well.
Can you hear me now better?
Okay, it's now better?
Now better?
[laughter] Okay, just tell
me how should I hold it?
Okay, the question is
when the Portuguese are
in the Red Sea defining Suez or
defining Akaba [Assumed Spelling],
places like this, which
were already known
about where the relative
position is to the Mediterranean
and when you have distortion
over in reality a short distance
but on the map a very wide
distance did anybody notice
that this can't be?
>> Joaquim Gaspar: Of course,
they knew they were distorted.
They knew in the Mediterranean,
they knew to determine exactly
the direction of the north,
the direction of the pull.
And I talked a little
bit about that.
Not only before the translation
of Bartholomew's geography,
they already knew where
the north is,
but after Bartholomew's
geography they had
to have a very strong reason to
defy the authority of the classics
and maintain the Mediterranean
tilted.
And the very strong
reason was navigation.
So only in the end of the
17th Century was the tilt
of the Mediterranean corrected.
That one thing, yes, they knew.
Maybe they didn't know the reason,
but they knew it was distorted,
they knew it was tilted.
The same thing for Africa,
not only for the stretching
and the distortions of the
coastlines but also for the mismatch
between Africa and
the Mediterranean.
Of course, the Isthmus
of Suez was enormous,
but those charts were intended
not to depict the world,
not to depict the landmasses,
but to navigate.
So the orientation
of the coastline had
to match the orientation
of the compass.
>> John Hessler: I think
what is unique in some ways
about Joaquim's work and
maybe this isn't coming
out clearly is Joaquim has basically
put forth an instrumental theory
of the Portolan Chart.
In other words, you can't
look at the Portolan Chart
like it's a geographic map.
If you look at a Portolan
Chart you've got
to realize what the
technology of navigation was.
This was supporting the
technology of navigation,
so it doesn't matter
how the chart looks.
It could look totally baffling to
us as far as accuracy and distances,
but when then you took it and
you used it with the tools
that were available for
navigation it worked as a diagram.
And all of these things have to be
brought together into the discussion
of what is principally a
nongeographic instrument,
and that really is the
difference in his work.
He has taken this out of the
history of cartography and put it
where it should be into the history
of navigation and technology.
And so all of those old
filogical tools, what the shape
of the coastline was, all that
kind of stuff are very immaterial
to these charts when you put them
in the context of navigation,
and that's the departure and
that really is the central -
when you look at Joaquim's
very technical work
and when he backs this up with his
mathematics it is 100% convincing
that to a certain extent we had
been looking at these things
in very primitive ways
for very long.
And so you can't throw out all of
the filogical and toponym work,
but really this technical
instrumental thing has kind
of revolutionized the study
of what a Portolan Chart is.
And I think you had a question?
[ Applause ]
>> Joaquim Gaspar: I
couldn't say it better.
Well, but this is not
an easy question.
The way charts were constructed
it's not easy, it's not immediate,
it's not by chance that historians
didn't reach the right explanation
before the present day.
Because it's a subtle technical
question, you've got to know
about navigation, about
theoretical cartography
and about history, of course.
>> John Hessler: And, by the way,
Joaquim before he got his
Ph.D. was a naval navigator
in the Portuguese Navy so, hence.
The microphone?
>> Related to that question
and because I'm not technical I
can't answer this, but if they got
to the same location in Egypt
or in that general area by going
through the Mediterranean
and also by navigating
around Africa are the
errors offsetting in that
or would they actually get
two different locations
for the same point?
>> Joaquim Gaspar: That
is an excellent question.
Thank you.
Well, they would get
different things, of course.
They got different things,
as a matter of fact,
because the eastern side of the
Mediterranean didn't match the tip
of the Red Sea, didn't
match the Isthmus of Suez.
Firstly, because of
magnetic declination,
but not only because there is
another problem is even a more
subtle problem which is the
fact that the earth is round
and they didn't consider
the roundness of the earth.
So everything you put on the
plane, every measurement you make
in the spherical earth and put
on the plane is geometrically
inconsistent.
And the final position of some
port depends on the way you use
to plot that part on the chart.
Did I answer your question?
>> John Hessler: And
one last question?
Arthur, go ahead?
>> I'm a little confused
at the end of all of this.
>> John Hessler: You're
where you started then?
>> Well, I've come full circle
to back where I've begun.
The [inaudible] map was 270
approximately degrees and one
of the revolutions of the
Waldseemuller 1507 map was
that it was a 360-degree view.
When we go to the 1516 map
and we're maybe somewhere
in between 270 and 360 degrees.
It's obviously not a 360-degree map.
So all this is quite clear.
Also, the fact that the
area that you've identified
as the Asian Peninsula on
the 1516 map is very similar
and probably copied from the
1507 map, is that correct?
But then we get to the two
cartouches [Assumed Spelling]
which clearly show two
separate hemispheres, I think,
in the 1507 map, an eastern
hemisphere and a western hemisphere.
The western hemisphere shows
what is apparently South America
and something else north.
If you look at the eastern cartouche
it also shows a fairly complete
picture of what was purported
to be Asia with a vast distance
between that and Chibango
[Assumed Spelling] or Japan.
How do you reconcile
those cartouches
with the other information
that you're presenting?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Well, I
will give you one example.
For instance, when you look
at the 1507 it shows a
fairly large continent.
That continent is only there,
that space is only there
so you can put the toponyms there.
Anyone that explored that
coast would not have gone more
than half a mile inland.
So on the 1507, although it looks
like a fairly significant strip
of land there, it's only there to
allow space to put the toponyms in.
And, again, on the west coast
of that it says they don't
know what's beyond here.
So really from that point to the end
you don't know whether it's land,
you don't know whether it's sea.
So when you combine those
two it really isn't a -
he put 360 degrees there,
but he didn't put 360
degrees of information there.
Does that make sense?
>> John Hessler: So, Arthur,
are you really asking
what the retraction is?
Is there some sort of
backward movement here or?
[ Inaudible ]
>> To the east of that there's
the Island of San Paolo and then
to the east of that there is Asia
or what purports to be Asia I mean
in contemporary vision, and I just
don't understand how you reconcile
that with your arguments?
>> Chet Van Duzer: With
the arguments that it's ...
>> That it's Asia?
>> Chet Van Duzer: That
it's Asia - oh, okay,
now I understand your question.
>> And, also, I mean if
you - and this is according
to my conversations
with John Hessler,
if you re-project the Ptolyemaic
view to a more regular view,
to the one that's portrayed
in the cartouches those
two are the same shape.
The shape of that what
you call narrow landmass,
which is now re-projected
to become the larger mass
in the right-hand cartouche,
that's pretty close
to what we might consider to
be the shape of South America.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes, let
me - and I can only talk
to the northwest continent - so
if you take Columbus' concept
of the size of the
earth it's much smaller.
Martellus, right, wasn't that
the gentleman, he believed that -
he did his own research on how
many miles there were to a degree
and his was much shorter.
I can't give you the exact
numbers, but we could talk
about it later, I can
find it for you.
So if you take his concept of how
big, the circumference of the earth,
number one, and then
you take his concept
of how far east Asia extended,
he believed along with Martellus
that Asia extended
much further east.
So if you take Columbus'
view of the size
of the earth plus the
eastern extent of Asia,
that triangle of Asia is
right where Florida is.
>> John Hessler: Well, I guess
we will leave it at that,
and you can see that
we've solved all
of these riddles of
cartography today.
I just want to invite all of
you, this evening is the annual,
2016 annual JI Kislak lecture.
It is going to be given by the
writer and renowned historian,
David Sobel, who is sitting
in the audience right here.
It is going to be on mapping the
southern hemisphere, another mystery
of cartography and astronomy.
And I would love for
all of you to come.
At the present moment, however,
I can invite all of you to go
out the door and make a left
directly into the Widdall Pavilion
and help yourselves
to a glass of wine.
And thank you, all, for coming.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.